the Joe Rogan experience did you see the
guy from empires speech like interview
yes yes yes that seems almost like he's
not pretend like he's if he's pretending
he's doing a better job acting them
joacquin findex what is Terrence Howard
a flower of life well Terrence Howard
the guy who interviewed me for Rolling
Stone told me the Terrence Howard is
like a legitimate genius like he said
you talked to the guy guys absolutely
brilliant maybe figured it all out I
think he got high as [ __ ] on DMT that's
what it sounds like you started figuring
all that yeah it does sound like that
right 100% yeah yeah it all makes sense
like it but the inability to explain it
just kind of like it's all connected but
he was not explaining it very well but
very articulately like he was using it
wasn't like nonsense talk right he was
like like oh this is like shockingly
coherent for a ridiculous thing to say
you've ever seen on to talk about what
happened to him Shane which one
che mas no he did I fo yeah no I had him
on back you which which what happened to
him though
I think he's in mushrooms everyday for a
month or DMT every day for a month and
he also covered himself in I'm getting
the terms long but maybe Syrian brew so
this [ __ ] couldn't come out of a system
and he went a little bit another how
long it was this mmm maybe a year and a
half ago okay so I hadn't before that
before so we went to see Roger Waters
he's got tickets for me in Providence I
went down there and he was like talking
like he was like I figured out these
math equations and he was like the whole
time was like dude I know I'm getting
I'm a science guy I get this seems
ridiculous I understand why you wouldn't
believe me but I can like figure [ __ ]
out to the point where mathematicians
are like mmm I never thought of it that
way he's like I don't understand how
it's possible but I get why you wouldn't
believe that yeah yeah he was like he
was you know when you're coming out of a
mushroom trip yeah for like 30 40
minutes you're like not quite coherent
cuz got a foot in there and a foot out
here he was like that for hours and I
guess for like months yeah it was just
cut in a constant state of coming out of
a mushroom trip I did DMT three times in
a day Wow the
third time it was a really strong one
and it [ __ ] me up for a while I don't
remember how long afterwards but this is
during the Fear Factor days but I
remember reality the way I described it
the reality was very slippery yeah very
slippery like I kept thinking that cars
we're gonna fly over the incoming lane
crashed into my car and kill me oh
really yeah I kept thinking like be
really careful but then I realized that
what that is is like my ego trying to
protect me by making me aware of
imminent threats and trying to
reestablish its position as in the the
chain of command because like one of the
things about really extreme psychedelic
experiences that they dissolve the ego
to the point where you realize like you
don't really matter like you're a part
of some crazy system and the only reason
why you think you really matters cuz
your biology wants to stay alive because
there's these inherent existential
threats to your existence that I've
always existed throughout time and you
know ultimately though it doesn't matter
because you're just gonna live and die
and probably live again I again and yeah
and you're part of some one of those
guys at any time you're like fighting it
like you're suck at it just means you
haven't taken enough I think that was
like Terence Mckenna or one of those
guys was like you just have to take more
and you can't fight it right you're gone
you know yeah but I was [ __ ] up for a
while really but I was functional I was
but I was real nervous and weirded out
by how long a long weeks maybe months
why'd you do it three times in a day
were you trying to do that on purpose or
the first time was light I went in but I
didn't go in too deep yeah but I saw the
visuals and I lay there and I was like I
got to the door and I could see through
the windows of the house but I didn't go
inside the second time it just like
opened up a [ __ ] vortex and shocked
me through to the center of the universe
and then it was really really really
intense and then I did it again after
that it's because I loved it because it
was so awesome I wanted to do one more
time I gotta do it more mmm vape pens
yeah that's what we should do on
November 1st
very pens yeah we should do DMT in the
mourner yeah in here you're gonna be in
New York oh yeah well as soon as we get
back kind of my apartment okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]